hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
so one of my last video we spoke about
viruses in this video we're going to
talk about bacteria and in particular
we'll focus on one type of bacteria
called a coli and how recent study has
shown that eco light can be forced to
grow on only carbon dioxide and this is
work taken from a cell paper that was
published in November last year some a
little bit late to the party but anyway
in this video we'll focus why they did
this study how they did it and what are
the next steps so to understand why they
did it we need to firstly discuss why
they chose eco life so eco light as a
bacterium it's very easy to engineer and
as you can see here it grows very
rapidly but to be able to grieve
bacterium need energy once they get this
energy from well bacteria get their
energy from respiration so we as humans
respire just like e.coli and the process
of respiration takes glucose and oxygen
and converts it into water and carbon
dioxide and the process of respiration
generates ATP which is the energy source
that our cells needs so as I said we
also respire like e.coli and also like
e-coli we are both referred to as
heterotrophs so what is a heterotroph so
simply put a hairy trace is a fancy term
used to describe organisms that use get
their carbon for biomass production from
organic organic compounds produced by
other organisms so this is the reason
why we eat food because we can't
actually make it ourselves not going to
complain about that do you like to eat
but whilst we respire like e-coli plants
also respire as well however they aren't
heterotrophs there instead referred to
as autotrophs so what makes plants
different is that they undergo
photosynthesis and they can use this
process to generate their own food so
they take carbon dioxide and they take
water and they convert this into glucose
and the release oxygen but whilst
respiration provides energy the key root
of photosynthesis is it requires energy
to
do you do reaction and so these also
train if these plants they can do
photosynthesis because they have carbon
dioxide fixing enzymes and they have a
harvesting complex that can collect this
energy that it requires to carry out
this process so what does paper sets out
to do was to see whether or not they
could convert eco light which is a
heterotroph into an auto truth which
means getting it to use carbon dioxide
as its food production source but why
actually bother with this in the first
place well we love plants well le
sighting and what plants do is they
assimilate the atmospheric carbon
dioxide into the production of feed
fuels and also by chemicals and so since
we're facing crop demand there's a huge
deforestation wouldn't be great if we
could use and culture eco lights you
achieve this instead so this brings me
on to the next question which is how can
this actually be achieved well there are
three main challenges that needs to be
addressed to be able to turn eco light
into autotrophs firstly they need to
have this calm the outside fixing
machinery and buy machinery and talking
about the proteins and enzymes needed to
catalyze the biochemical reactions and
then secondly they need to get this
energy source as a reducing power to
carry out the process and then lastly
you need a way to regulate and
coordinates the carbon dioxide fixing
machinery with the energy reduction
synthesis as well so the solution
discussed in this paper has a
two-pronged approach firstly they used
genetic engineering and they couple this
with the use of adaptive laboratory
evolution so firstly let's talk about
genetic engineering which is simply just
manipulating the genes present in the
bacterium so what they did was to solve
the first problem about having the
carbon dioxide fixing machinery as well
you guess that they added the genes that
enable this to happen and so two of the
genes they added was Rubisco and
phosphorylase kinase but the problem is
they sort of this reducing power as well
and so they're reducing power and tons
of
powering the places in this reaction is
it comes from the reduced form of NAD+
which is NADH and so they needed to
generate nadh and plants got this from
energy from light energy but obviously
they need an alternative strategy for
e.coli so they did this by using for me
to generate nadh electrochemically and
the reason that this works is that vomit
is more electro chemically negative than
nad plus and say electron transfer goes
to nad past and he generates nadh so to
the university needed to also add
formate dehydrogenase to the bacterium
so that they could actually process for
mates okay why I won't for that quite
fast you might have to watch it unlike
point five speed or something but anyway
the sub parts of the story is that bit
of this and this alone wasn't enough for
the bacterium to depend solely on carbon
dioxide for its biomass accumulation so
they needed a couple this with adaptive
lab evolution which is definitely a
rational approach because you can use
the power of evolution to come up with
the solution to this problem and so you
adaptive laboratory evolution is kind of
putting my style decides you have your
bacterium and you grade them in the kind
of decides conditions that you're
looking for and this enables the e.coli
with the desired traits to grow faster
or enable some the more likely to
survive and he just repeat this process
and you're going to enhance the
proportion of bacterium that have the
traits that you're looking for and then
you can see at the end of it and they
did this for one year what has changed
in e.coli and this can by finding the
mutations you can try to understand how
the e.coli evolved in this case to be
able to eat carbon dioxide so justify
the restraints going through this
evolution process the bacteria are going
to grow and as they grow they accumulate
mutations and so there were three
categories of mutations that they found
in the e.coli population that
successfully grew slowly and comedy
and the first category were found in
genes directly linked to carbon dioxide
fixation which kind of makes sense in
this case right and then the second
category of mutations that they found
what in genes that are kind of that
commonly found or they crop up in
experiments that use this adaptive
laboratory evolution and so these
include genes such as genes that
regulate gene expression and protein
synthesis and see the kind of make sense
that maybe by altering the global rates
of the bacterium it could enable some
degree faster than others so it could
still be interesting to find out what
genes in particular are mutated and then
lastly they found mutations and other
genes that look I guess was somewhat
unexpected and so these either require
further testing or they could just be
bystanders so I told you why I've told
you how what is the next steps with this
study well
as they described it's pretty much a
proof of concept paper they've shown
that it's possible to take an e.coli
which is a heterotroph and converts it
into an auto trace however one of the
motivations for the study was to find a
way to use carbon monoxide instead of
producing it but the current strategy
uses four mate and by using four mate
they actually have a net gain of carbon
dioxides
so in the future they hoped a couple the
formate use to a renewable energy source
so they're not quite there yet but they
are definitely in the right direction
and I really like this quote from the
paper which is the establishment of
synthetic called the trophy demonstrates
the incredible plasticity of central
metabolism and could provide a framework
for future carbon neutral by production
pretty awesome a he knew metabolism
could be so fun
so check out the paper it's a really
good read and as always thanks for
listening